yeah yeah I even though I'm trying to
become a super delegate I've just a
delegate now I want to get my cape for
crying out loud I want to get my super
powers yeah of course I am I worried
about anything that is going to be
perceived to threaten the legitimacy of
the process within our party and it'll
be problematic if at the end of the day
there are democratic voters who become
cynical about the process because they
believe it wasn't fair and that's a
that's a real legitimate worry but we're
far away away from that and i think that
the leadership within the Democratic
Party understands that as well and I
have faith that the that the right will
prevail and I also AM think on a part of
the process now that I could at least
let my voice be heard as we as we
hopefully go to that end